que le ministre avec gravité moi je vais
aller un peu plus loin monsieur
Kerrouche je pense que votre volonté
d'opposition à la réforme et peut-être
plus forte que notre volonté de voter
cette réforme eh oui mais seulement pour
nous il y a quelque chose qui est sacré
et c'est à la différence de vous ce sont
les institutions il Sénat ah oui si si
oui oui c'est sacré cette chose là et
vous jouez avec les allumettes vous
jouez avec les allumettes car le
Parlement je vous ai beaucoup écouté le
Parlement pardonnez-moi je vous ai
beaucoup écouté
mais non monsieur kaner vous êtes mal à
l'aise depuis le début monsieur Kanner
parce que vous êtes déposé dépassé par
votre base radicale mais laissez-nous
parler autrement vous feriez pas ça
alors un peu de silence un peu de
respect
vous respirez le mal-être vous respirez
le mal-être monsieur caner pour respirer
le mal-être mais pour nous les
institutions elles sont sacrées elles
sont sacrées oh là elles sont sacrées le
Parlement c'est débattre on veut
débattre mais il y a une différence
entre vous et nous depuis le début c'est
que nous on veut débattre mais on veut
voter voter c'est ça aussi le Parlement
votez et depuis le début vous faites
tout pour nous empêcher de voter nous
exprimer voilà et voyez il y a peut-être
une arrière-pensée parce qu'il y a
toujours des arrières pensées en
politique l'arrière pensée c'est que
vous vous dites on va peut-être tirer
les bénéfices
de cette crise ou cette difficulté mais
c'est pas vous détrompez-vous c'est le
populisme et les populistes qui vont
tirer les bénéfices et donc nous on est
attaché au Sénat aux institutions à la
démocratie représentative c'est la
raison pour laquelle on est solidaire
avec le président dans le Sénat il faut
débattre et voter voilà l'essentiel je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]